[MUSIC PLAYING]
[APPLAUSE]
MARCUS GRIMALDO: This year's
theme is really special to us,
I think, given what's
going on in the world
and how we want to be able to
go about it in a productive way
that is impactful,
that is sensible,
and that is endearing
in the sense
that you can take away
something that is meaningful.
This year's theme for
HOLA on the campus--
that's our Hispanic chapter,
by the way, and it is global--
is [SPANISH]--
hear me.
Right, what does that mean?
How does each one
conceptualize that?
And so when we look at
that theme and the artwork
that you all have
chosen to bring,
I think there's
a lot of synergy.
I think there's a
lot of alignment.
I think that there's
a lot behind that what
we see in the Boardwalk Cafe.
If you all know
that artists here,
their artwork is displayed
in the Boardwalk Cafe
and they've done a great job.
And so today, we're really
going to use this opportunity
to see what is behind the art.
Who is behind the artists--
what that narrative is?
And I'm a big believer
in narratives.
I think everyone has a story,
or at least they should.
And if you don't have
one, you can kind of
make one up like,
oh, you know, I came
from the Bronx or something.
Everybody loves the
Bronx story, right?
I'm totally joking.
No, but I have been
researching these three artists
this past week and am
super excited for this talk
to get to know them
on an intimate level
and evoke a sense of who they
are and what [SPANISH] means.
So we're going to
talk about all of this
as we encounter this discussion.
So we'll start with our first
artist here, Margaret Garcia,
born in East Los Angeles.
You've seen her work around the
1984 Olympics possibly, LACMA,
the Laguna Art Museum,
and even Cheech Marin.
All right, this is awesome.
I spent some time
on the website and I
was like, wow, who doesn't
know Cheech and Chong?
And if you don't, I'd say make
that a Netflix and chill night.
It's super funny.
And she has a story that
is just absolutely amazing.
We want to learn about it.
And so in essence, she
is a working, thriving,
and recognized artist.
Ladies and gentlemen, let's
give her a hand and welcome her.
[APPLAUSE]
So Margaret, before we get into
the painting that you see here
or your artistic expression
that's there-- and I mean,
god, it's Selena, right?
She's been gone
for over 20 years.
She's timeless
almost, in a sense.
And she's a legend
and legends never die.
Talk to us about who you are.
You're from Los Angeles.
We've had a chance,
an opportunity
to talk a little bit
about who you are.
I was excited about your story.
You know, how did you come
into this working, thriving,
and recognized artists?
MARGARET GARCIA: Well,
I was born in East LA
to an undocumented person--
my mother-- but my
father was born here.
My grandmother was born
in Texas and her mother--
my great-grandmother-- and
my great-great-grandmother
came to El Paso.
They were Tarahumara
from Chihuahua.
And they were here
a long time ago.
My great-grandmother lived
in the Santa Clara Village
down on Virgil Street
near the metro station.
But my father was born here.
His mother was born here.
He was repatriated to Mexico.
His father went with
him-- my grandfather.
And I found the paperwork
of my grandfather, who
was Apache, living on a
reservation in Arizona
and working there.
And his registration for
the draft for World War I--
I find this, right?
MARCUS GRIMALDO: Wow.
MARGARET GARCIA: And yet,
he's repatriated along
with my father and
his two brothers.
And his eldest brother drowns on
the trip back through Tijuana.
He absconded with the children
and then was repatriated,
and so he was
raised near Obregón,
Sonora in a little
[INAUDIBLE] village.
You know, he was Apache,
but you know the thing
that I think a lot
of Americans do not
understand about the
Mexican experience--
the Chicano
experience-- because I'm
sort of that subset of group.
I'm Chicana, you know.
--is that he's Apache, and
the Yaqui and the Apache
are kind of like family.
They're like different
clans of the same people.
And one of the
reasons why we hold on
so dearly to the terminology
of that-- and other Latinos
don't understand it
because they say, well,
but you're not including us.
It isn't that we want
to exclude people.
I think we are very
inclusive, but the terminology
that links us to this land
continually and perpetually
makes us the immigrant,
whether we are or we are not.
And my father was born here.
His mother was born here.
They're from indigenous people
who are from this continent.
We are not really
the immigrant, but we
are the perpetual immigrant.
And that's something that
people do not understand.
And it's one of the reasons
why people like me--
born in the '50s--
people call me Chicanosaurus or
whatever they want to call me.
[LAUGHTER]
I'm good with that, you know.
MARCUS GRIMALDO: It's the
first I've heard of that,
but I love it.
MARGARET GARCIA: Yeah,
you know, stuck in it,
but that's fine for me
because I understand
how important that
piece of heritage
is to us because
Mexicanos-- all of them--
they're not all immigrants.
And California-- and I
did the metro station
at the Campo de Cahuenga where
the capitulation of Cahuenga
was signed making California a
territory of the United States.
This was Mexico, people.
So that's really difficult
for people to understand,
but it's a very,
very deep heritage.
And yes, we have a
lot of connections
with the rest of the
Latinos of Central
and South America
and everything else,
but I can't give that up yet.
MARCUS GRIMALDO:
No, you know what?
And I completely
understand that.
And I get that totally
because my grandfather
on the Mexican side had a
ranch in San Antonio, Texas.
And so in that sense, before it
was that, it was always Mexico.
So the family had it
for centuries, right?
So it's like we didn't
cross the border,
the borders crossed
us type of thing.
MARGARET GARCIA: Absolutely.
MARCUS GRIMALDO: And he married
my grandmother Guadalupe who--
you want to tell us
a little bit about?
You touched upon
her a little bit.
But when I was
reading your story,
that hit home for me because--
God rest her soul-- but yeah,
who is Guadalupe to you?
MARGARET GARCIA: My
grandmother adopted
a little girl named Guadalupe.
And she died of
tuberculosis of the bone
in the communicable diseases
ward at the general hospital.
And then she found
my father again
and he came back to
live with her after he
was being raised in Sonora.
And my mother came--
illegally, she crossed.
And my grandmother
was a bit of a coyote,
and so what she did
was she gave my mother
those papers that showed--
so she was using
Guadalupe's papers.
So when I was born, the name
on the birth certificate
said Guadalupe, so I have a
two-page birth certificate
that corrected that.
We went and we corrected
all that stuff.
And my mother became
an American citizen.
MARCUS GRIMALDO:
Wow, that's amazing.
And just listening
to your story,
you said a couple of things--
repatriated.
MARGARET GARCIA: Yes.
MARCUS GRIMALDO: I think
that almost hits home
because it's kind of what
almost pretty much has went on
just recently, right?
So can we get a little bit
deeper on like repatriated?
What does that mean
and then how do you
parallel that to like
what happened today?
I mean, what do you
think of that as far as--
I mean, that's a
long time, but it
sounds like it kind of happened
today with what, you know,
the current state of just
where we were at, right?
MARGARET GARCIA:
I think if you're
looking at the Mexican history,
obviously there's racism.
They're not looking at white
people to say, you know,
your mother was from here or not
here or whatever they're doing.
And I'm not sure if
I'm making sense.
You know, back in the '30s, they
literally just went into places
and if you were
Mexican, it didn't
matter if you were born here
or you weren't born here.
They didn't look at your papers.
They just rounded people
up on cattle cars,
like my uncle and
his two sisters.
My father's cousins
were literally
rounded up out of first and
second grade and kindergarten,
put on an open cattle
car with their father--
they were born here as well,
as well as their mother--
and put on that open
cattle car where it rained
and they were shipped all the
way down to central Mexico
to make it hard
for them to return.
And they sat in that open
cattle car for days, you know,
shivering and not being
fed and disposed of.
There was no compassion for
them or their status at all.
MARCUS GRIMALDO: And
this was in the--
what year time frame?
MARGARET GARCIA: It was in the
'30s, but what was interesting
with my uncle who was
repatriated, born here,
his mother was here--
he goes down to Mexico and he
says, the only thing I wanted
was to get an education.
All I wanted was an education.
So he goes to the Mexican
schools down there
and they say, oh, no.
You're an American.
You have an American
birth certificate.
We won't let you take the
place of another Mexican child.
So they wouldn't
educate him here
and they yanked him
out of school there.
So that meant that the
only education he got
was before they yanked
him out of that classroom
and took him down there.
MARCUS GRIMALDO: Wow.
And that was in the '30s.
We saw something like
that now, so that's really
something that is interesting.
MARGARET GARCIA: Just
to be fair, I mean,
look at what happened
to the Okies.
Those are white people
crossing the country.
So it isn't-- you know, whether
it's race or class or somebody
trying to find a reason that
you're lesser than human to say
they're taking
something from us.
The Mexicanos who come
here come here to work.
They come here to work
and they work hard.
They do jobs that
nobody else wants
and they contribute
to the economy.
[APPLAUSE]
MARCUS GRIMALDO: Yeah.
Wow.
Well, I get to see
it on the website
and I love it even in person.
It's just so much more, and
it's so rich, and so many
things for us.
At Google, we're all about
impacting the folks--
the people-- in the best way
possible with our technology,
so these issues are
definitely important to us
here and abroad as well.
So I'm going to switch gears
a little bit because we've got
a little bit of who you are.
Thank you so much
for sharing with us.
We have the artist
that you see here.
Like I said, she
was, I think, highly
impactful for us and
I think everybody
has their own connection
to her in some way.
And it's globally, right?
We saw Drake wearing
a Selena T-shirt.
We saw Leslie Grace
dominicana wearing a T-shirt.
I mean, support for her has
just been so tremendous,
generations beyond, right?
And so what was your
inspiration for this
and what about her touched you?
And talk to us.
Can you walk us through that?
MARGARET GARCIA: Well,
honestly speaking,
I was approached
by a developer who
was looking for a piece of art.
You know, there's
the 1% for art,
and myself, and
two other artists.
It was for a location
that dealt with mariachis.
And I said, well, you
need to honor musicians.
And I thought of two people.
And the first one was Selena.
The second person
was Lalo Guerrero,
but I really wanted a woman
because oftentimes, there's
not as many of us.
You know what I mean.
[LAUGHTER]
So you know it's important
to support the women.
And she's beautiful.
She's from Texas where
my grandmother is from.
So I thought she's the one.
She's the one that I need to
honor in this particular way.
I can't dig her up and
ask her to sit for me.
I only have the images
that exist of her
as they exist of her.
So it was about me
reinterpreting them and trying
to make it look like a
stained glass window.
And the thing about
stained glass windows
is there's always a
sense of sacredness.
It's a spiritual experience.
And so that's what I went for.
MARCUS GRIMALDO: That's amazing.
I mean, I got
chills looking at it
because it's just so fantastic.
And I think you're right.
I think that's what it was.
It was like there's
something familiar about it.
I didn't quite know how
to put the pulse on it,
but I think you hit it.
It's very sacred.
You know, you see that
and now that's fantastic.
Now, you mentioned
there's three of them.
We had a chance to
talk before, right?
And you did three of them.
This was the biggest.
Who has the other two?
Can you share?
MARGARET GARCIA: I do.
MARCUS GRIMALDO: Oh, you do.
OK, who are you saving them for?
I want one.
MARGARET GARCIA:
They're different.
Each one is a little different.
The other two are
done in steel boxes.
So I actually try to show
it in the dark instead
of trying to light it because
the light comes from the back,
and so you don't need to
light it because it glows.
MARCUS GRIMALDO: Wow.
MARGARET GARCIA: So the boxes
were intended to do that,
but then I found
this other person
who started talking to me about
shattered plate glass windows.
And he was a glass guy and
he talked about the effect.
And he said that I could--
it's called I want to say cold
bonding or cold laminating.
There's a process.
So he walked me
through that and so
I put the shattered
glass on the outside.
It makes it tough to
handle, but you're not
supposed to handle it.
So if you've got your hands
on my art, take them off.
You'll get cut.
MARCUS GRIMALDO: No touching.
MARGARET GARCIA: No touching
because you will get cut.
MARCUS GRIMALDO: Only look.
And then lastly, this is
just one representation
of what she does by the way.
There's other forms of
expression or artwork
that you have.
Do you want to just kind of
give us a little bit more
insight to that?
We will have this also posted
on our websites as well locally,
so for the rest
of the folks that
are watching that are here, stay
tuned because that is to come.
But I want you to
kind of give us
a little sneak peek
into what to expect.
MARGARET GARCIA:
Well, I've done a lot
of portraits in the beginning.
And one of the reasons
I've done portraits
is because I felt it was
important for my community
to define ourselves from within
and not be defined by what
the media wants to call us.
So if you see
yourself in the media
and you're maybe a gardener,
a housekeeper, a gangbanger,
or any of the other
negative things
that I care not to repeat, and
they're talking ill about you,
part of that is because
other people are defining you
and they don't know who you are.
They don't know us.
They don't know us if they think
that we're those things that
have been repeated by 45.
The only thing I can say is--
my brother is sitting in
the audience right now.
He's a doctor.
He's a trauma surgeon.
We are people who have
accomplished things.
We are people who have done
things and have contributed.
Whether you're talking about
science, innovation, medicine,
arts, we're here and we are
part of the American fabric.
MARCUS GRIMALDO: Thank you.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
All right, Manuel Lopez.
Sorry, you know, her
story was so good it made
your back pop off, didn't it?
MANUEL LOPEZ: Yeah, it did.
MARCUS GRIMALDO:
It felt it, huh?
The chair even felt it.
Sorry about that, but so
glad to have you here.
Manuel Lopez--
another Angeleno--
grew up in East Los Angeles.
I read your story.
I don't want to talk too much
because I want to hear it
from you, but it's so
funny because as a kid,
it started with a
competition with his sister
on a who could draw the
better Trix rabbit--
bunny rabbit.
And then he ran with
that and he ended up
getting so excited
about "Mario Kart"
that he painted his whole TV
at his home at eight years old,
I believe--
the whole TV as a Mario canvas.
Mom was not happy.
And then he's been around.
He attended East
Los Angeles college.
He transferred to the School of
the Art Institute of Chicago.
And he was featured in
the "LA Times" article.
And that must have been a
big, big moment for you.
So ladies and gentlemen,
let's give him a warm welcome
of applause and let's
get to know him.
[APPLAUSE]
MANUEL LOPEZ: Thank you.
MARCUS GRIMALDO: So
Manuel, talk to me.
I kind of gave us the low down--
a little bit about who you are.
But I mean, I look
at your artwork
and what you've done here.
And I was telling, I think it
was you as a matter of fact--
no, Nilza, excuse me.
I was telling Nilza, who is
our business partner here
and facilitated the
artists coming here,
so thank you so much.
We had a chance to talk, and
I said I feel like this is--
the artwork brings
us kind of here
and there at the same time.
And when I mean that, the
East Los Angeles landscape,
but it's very reminiscent of
Mexico, at least that's what
I get from this expression.
So talk to me about growing
up, how this became something
for you, what you've done,
all the accomplishments you've
done with the Los
Angeles article,
and then where
you plan on going.
MANUEL LOPEZ: Well,
I guess I started
drawing when I was
very young, I mean,
as far as back as
I can remember.
That was a very
vivid memory that I
have from my childhood when I
used to compete with my sister.
It was just for the fun of it.
I guess my dad will
get a kick out of it.
So I mean, I always
realize that drawing came
more easy than with other kids.
So it was just-- it
came really easy.
I could just see things
and just put them on paper.
I never really
took it seriously.
It was always a game to me.
I mean, I just really
enjoyed doing it.
I grew up in Boyle Heights.
And then at about age,
I think, eight or nine,
we moved to East LA.
And I remember, like, moving
the stuff from our old house
to our new house in East LA.
And I remember looking at
the City Terrace hills.
And they just left--
I don't know, I just
saw them and I thought
they looked really beautiful.
Night came, and the
sun was just setting,
and the lights were turning on.
And I remember saying like,
wow, can this get any better?
It was to me, it just
really spoke to me.
And then I started thinking
about the people who
lived up there.
And so I left it at that
for a really long time.
I kept making drawings
after drawing after drawing.
This was from when I
was about 10 to 18.
I never took an art
class in high school.
Well, I went over to ELAC,
met some good people there--
a good instructor by
the name of Jim Uyekawa.
And he just started to put
the idea in me that it's fun,
but also it takes a discipline.
It takes discipline, and it
takes time, and it takes work.
And I was 18, so I didn't
take it too seriously.
You know, like I would
still goof around,
but I still kept at it.
And luckily, a couple years
after I enrolled at ELAC,
I put a portfolio
together and I got
accepted to the School of
the Art Institute of Chicago.
I had done some research.
I was checking for major
schools that were in the US.
I looked at Rhode
Island School of Design.
I looked at the School of
the Art Institute of Chicago.
Then I took a trip out there.
I visited both campuses.
And the School of the Art
Institute by far was, I mean,
they just had this beautiful
collection of all sorts of art.
And to be able to look at
it while studying, I think
was definitely like a prize
because I love to look at art.
I mean, I love to make it.
I like to look at it as well.
What else?
MARCUS GRIMALDO: So if we
were looking at these three
paintings here, how
does that come about?
What's the inspiration?
I know you mentioned it seems
like landscape is definitely
at the forefront of how you
envision things, and what
inspires you, and what
compels you, right?
So when you start with the
landscape and the vision,
what's that process like?
For us that aren't
artists that don't know,
but that are super
excited and they're like,
how does something so
simple and beautiful happen?
And is it as easy as it looks?
Is it harder?
Educate us a little bit on that
process, if you don't mind.
MANUEL LOPEZ: Well,
these paintings
were started off as-- they
started off as drawings.
I usually always work on-site.
I take paper, pencil, and
I spend a couple of times--
I don't mean a couple of
times-- a couple of hours
up on the hillside.
I mean, I think it's very
meditative to just sit out
there by yourself, and you're
confronting the whole landscape
in front of you, and you
know that you're part of it,
and you're looking
at these houses which
hold people that
are contributing
to the American society.
And so just like Margaret
said that our lives are not
in the media--
in the popular media--
you know, I mean, those
houses hold everything
from the gangster
to the mechanic that
works 80 hours a week.
And just being up there
as the sun is setting,
those hills just come alive.
You get people
coming in from work.
You have kids running
down the street.
You have the paletero
selling his stuff.
You have the paisas coming
along with the Chalino blasting.
And you smell the carne asada
and it just it feels good.
It feels, you know--
and I'm part of it, you know.
When I look at them--
like a lot of people
have been telling me
that it reminds them of Mexico,
but I mean, I've been to Mexico
and it doesn't really
remind me of Mexico.
But I mean, to each his own.
But I mean, I think
when I'm making this,
I'm aware that I come
from Southern California
and I love--
I came across David Hockney's
work some years ago.
And I love the way
he captures light.
And so I'm aware that I
come from that tradition.
Even though he's
from England, he
landed in Southern California
and he made Southern California
his playground.
I'm looking at other
artists like Ed Ruscha.
I'm looking at the
artists that I couldn't
see when I was younger because
I was walking on the streets
and I would see a
mural by Frank Romero.
I would see a mural
by David Botello.
So in a way, like
when I saw Hockney,
it was something new for me.
So these guys right here,
I think more than anything,
I think they're
Southern California.
I'm trying to capture the sun.
I'm trying to capture
the palm trees, I think.
I think just when you
look at the landscape,
I think I get excited by looking
at all the different trees,
at all the different life forms.
This is their environment and
we're part of it, you know.
MARCUS GRIMALDO:
Yeah, I love that.
It's like you said it
was meditative to you.
I think it's very therapeutic
for us here just listening
to that.
And then even more exciting
and honorable on your behalf
is that you're representing that
community to the fullest in one
of the most unique ways.
Like, not everybody
could do that,
so that's absolutely fantastic.
I want to switch gears.
I do want to talk about
the "LA Times" article.
I think that's a
huge accomplishment.
I had a chance--
an opportunity to read
it multiple times.
How did that happen?
Did you expect that?
Did you ever think that at
this time in your career,
it would happen?
I mean, you seem pretty young,
so that's a big accomplishment
to get that visibility,
that presence.
That's awesome.
And again, you are
the LA story, right?
And so what better
way to have somebody
highlight that and showcase than
the "LA Times" article, right?
So can you talk us
through that journey,
and how it happened,
when it happened,
what does it mean, has
it been impactful for you
as an artist--
your career?
MANUEL LOPEZ: So the
story came about like,
I usually like, kick it with
friends that are into the arts.
Like, they do
photography or they drum.
And we go hit up the hills.
We'll go up there for
a couple of hours.
And then one of them
is a photographer.
His name is Rafael Cardenas.
And he tells me one day, hey,
let me follow you around.
Let me, you know, just
pretend I'm not even there.
You do your thing.
And I'll try to stay
out of your way.
And I'm like, well, fuck it.
Let's do it.
So we went up.
He followed me around for
maybe like about seven hours.
You know?
We hit up three different
spots in City Terrace.
No, two spots in City
Terrace, one in Elysian Park.
So we went around.
He said, like,
hey, man, I'm going
to do like a little video
montage of everything
I captured.
I'm like, go for it, man.
Just make me look--
you know, look good.
You know?
So he's like, dude, I
don't promise anything.
You know?
And I'm like, no, I'm
just messing around, man.
Do whatever you need to do.
And he-- you know, he--
a couple months pass.
I didn't hear anything from him.
And then like, out of the blue,
he tells me, you know what?
I'm done with the editing.
And if you want to check
it out, come through.
I stopped by.
I checked it out.
I was like, damn.
Like, I was--
I think the way he just
filmed everything was really,
it was amazing.
There was beautiful music in the
background by some guy, Arenas.
I don't know if you guys
have heard of Chicano Batman?
Yeah, so he goes--
MARCUS GRIMALDO:
I'm hearing some--
yeah, so [INAUDIBLE].
I gotta check him out.
MANUEL LOPEZ: He did
the background music
and beautifully composed.
You know?
He puts it on his website.
And I'm like, OK,
that's cool, you know?
Like, I was really--
I was happy for him.
Because it was his first
like editing video.
Because he's usually
shooting photos.
And so a couple of weeks
after he puts it online,
I get a call from my girlfriend.
And she tells me, you know what?
Like, Rafael just called me up.
And he tells me to tell
you to check your email.
I don't have a cellphone.
I've been cellphone-free
for about seven years.
MARCUS GRIMALDO: I'm sorry?
Wait, can you say
that one more--
wait, did I hear that correctly?
You don't have a cellphone?
And you haven't had a
cellphone for seven years?
MANUEL LOPEZ: Seven years.
Yeah.
MARCUS GRIMALDO: Wow.
MANUEL LOPEZ: So every time
people want to contact me--
MARCUS GRIMALDO: They've got
to go through the girlfriend.
MANUEL LOPEZ: I
don't even know, man.
I don't know how
they do it, man.
It's pretty amazing.
They get to track me down.
You know?
But anyways, so
I check my email.
And then I read the email from,
her name is Esmeralda Bermudez.
And she tells me, you
know, I saw Rafael's video.
And I was wondering if
I could interview you
for a future piece.
And at first, I didn't
know what to think.
Because I was like,
wow, the "LA Times."
So I'm like, well, yeah,
let's make it happen.
She hits me up.
We go to the local cafe.
She interviews me
for about two hours.
MARCUS GRIMALDO: Wow.
MANUEL LOPEZ: I'm
like, OK, that's cool.
We went into it.
We spoke.
We had lunch.
We drank coffee.
And then she's like,
oh, this is really good.
When can we do it again?
So I'm like, what the fuck?
Dude, we did two hours.
And then she wants more?
I'm like, let's do it next week.
And she's like, all right.
And then we do that.
And then again, hey,
let's do it again.
I'm like, dang.
All right.
So two more hours
and then I don't
know how many times we met.
But it was just really good.
Like it was--
I guess the word I want
to use is kind of therapy.
Because she was really trying
to go deep into the practice
and why I do what I do.
And I mean, it was a really
beautiful experience.
And then she's
like, OK, it's over.
And then she's like, I'm
going to bring the "LA Times"
photographer.
I'm like, what?
MARCUS GRIMALDO: Oh, so you
didn't know the whole time
it was for "LA Times?"
MANUEL LOPEZ: Well, I knew
it was from the "LA Times."
But I didn't know that they
were going to be shooting.
MARCUS GRIMALDO: Oh,
and when was this?
MANUEL LOPEZ: This was
a couple of months ago.
I think April.
MARCUS GRIMALDO: Oh,
this was very recent.
MANUEL LOPEZ: April, yeah.
MARCUS GRIMALDO: That's awesome.
And it's out.
This is public.
People can go online.
MANUEL LOPEZ: Yeah, it's
on the "LA Times" link.
And so she brings the
photographer over.
And I'm like, dude, I'm going to
take you guys up to the hills.
That's my natural landscape.
You know?
And so we take the
photographer up there.
And he's setting up his
flashes and all that stuff.
And he's like, all
right, just sit down.
You know, do your thing.
And then I start drawing.
She's like behind me.
She's like still
asking me questions.
And then the photographer,
after we're all done,
he's like hanging off the
side of the cliff trying
to take a good shot of me.
And then very seriously after
we're done, he comes up to me
and he tells, hey,
man, you know what?
I've been to Iraq.
I've been to Baghdad.
He's like, but this is the
hardest excitement ever, man.
MARCUS GRIMALDO: Wow,
you deserve a round
of applause for that one.
That's awesome.
That's great.
So what are we to expect next?
Is there another article
that's coming out?
Are you kind of just taking
a break from, you know,
and working on the
next inspiration?
What's the--
MANUEL LOPEZ: After that
article, I had a solo show.
I had my first solo show at
Eastern Projects in Chinatown.
MARCUS GRIMALDO: Wow, OK.
Is there any more coming up
that we should be aware of here?
MANUEL LOPEZ: Well, I mean,
I'm pretty sure something
will come up in the future.
But for right now
I'm just working.
MARCUS GRIMALDO: Got it.
MANUEL LOPEZ: And there's
several exhibitions
that are being lined up.
But I mean, if you guys want
to follow me on Instagram,
it's M-E-A-U-N-L. And
I'll be posting stuff up.
I mean, it's just a plug.
But fuck, you might as
well take advantage.
You know?
MARCUS GRIMALDO: You
beat me to the punch.
I was like, we're
going to do-- we're
going to do all that stuff.
MANUEL LOPEZ:
Well, yeah, I mean,
I just don't want to
say it like right now.
Because it's just in the works.
And I mean, I feel like it's
good stuff that's coming.
You know?
I mean, I've been at
this for a lot of years,
quietly just working
and working and working.
And I think that's
like the thing.
I mean, the thing is
that for that show,
I put in a bunch of drawings.
And everybody was
telling me, you
know, oh, these are beautiful.
They're great.
And I was like, oh.
Like, don't get me wrong.
I thought that was really great.
But it's just like
after the show,
it's just like it's
crazy when it hits you.
You know, it's like, for
every successful drawing,
there was 30 drawings
that didn't make it.
You know what I mean?
So I think it's just work.
Like, you just need to
work and work and work.
And I mean, something good
eventually will come out of it.
MARCUS GRIMALDO: I agree.
I agree.
And we're here to support you.
So we look forward
to hearing when
the next thing is happening.
And we're going to exchange
social media, Twitter, all
that fun stuff in a little bit.
But I'm going to go ahead and
introduce our final artist,
Señor Antonio Pelayo.
Thank you so much
for being here.
Let's give him a warm
welcome, ladies and gentlemen.
[APPLAUSE]
ANTONIO PELAYO: Is this on?
MARCUS GRIMALDO: Is it on?
ANTONIO PELAYO: Yeah, right?
MARCUS GRIMALDO: There we go.
Yeah, sounds good.
So I was reading up on you too.
And we had a chance to talk
a little bit before, as well.
You have a very, very
interesting background.
Again, being here, there,
so from Glendale to Mexico,
back to Glendale, and then
the whole Disney experience.
Right?
A lot to unpack there.
I think you describe
yourself as an illustrator
and a hyper-realist, right?
And then when we look
at this piece here,
it represents what you
called photorealism.
So we have a lot to unpack here.
So talk to me.
Talk to me about the evolution
of you, your artistry.
And then we can go from there.
ANTONIO PELAYO: Well to
make a long story short,
I used to live in Highland Park
and I used to go to preschool.
The preschool was right
across from our house.
And in preschool,
all we did was art.
So I started drawing since
I was like, I don't know,
three years old.
Shortly after that,
my mom started
studying with a religious
group that's very--
I don't want to say
the name of the group.
I don't want to offend anyone.
But it's a very difficult
religion to be a part of.
Due to that, my dad sent us
to Mexico to their small town.
It's called [INAUDIBLE].
Back in '79, I don't know,
maybe a couple hundred people
lived there.
And that's where both
my parents are from.
So he sent us there with
the intention of the family
to turn my mom and
my sisters and myself
back to being Catholic.
We were the only ones
from that religion there.
But instead of that
happening, my mom
became a stronger
member of that religion.
So we were in Mexico
from '79 to '89.
During that time, being
part of that religion,
you're not allowed to
associate or hang out
with anyone else that's
not part of that religion.
So I really had no friends.
So my only friend
really was me drawing.
I would just lock myself up
and draw, and draw all day.
And so that's most of
what I did in Mexico,
and be part of that religion.
I mean, I was running
congregations when I was,
like, 15 years old.
So it's now '89.
We came back to the States.
And we weren't supposed
to come back and stay.
My mom just one day
told my dad, you know,
we're going to
come and visit you.
And I was supposed
to stay in Mexico.
But then everyone started
crying the night before.
And then everyone's like,
all right, pack your stuff.
We're going to take you with us.
So we came here.
And we ended up just staying.
So shortly after that,
right out of high school,
I got hired by Disney in
a very small department,
a department that
was started back
in the '20s by Walt Disney.
And that department was
all women back then.
And so--
MARCUS GRIMALDO: Oh,
that's different.
ANTONIO PELAYO: Yeah.
MARCUS GRIMALDO: Right?
ANTONIO PELAYO: It's so weird.
Because I don't know.
The department's going
to turn 100 in 2023.
Forward to today, now
that department's all men.
MARCUS GRIMALDO: Oh.
ANTONIO PELAYO: Yeah, they just
hired my son about a year ago.
And then we hired
another gentleman.
MARCUS GRIMALDO: And that's
the ink and paint department--
ANTONIO PELAYO: Ink and
paint department, yeah.
MARCUS GRIMALDO: --you were
just talking about, right?
ANTONIO PELAYO: Yeah.
MARCUS GRIMALDO: For us,
again, we're not artists here.
Well, I'm not definitely.
And I don't know if anybody
else in the audience is.
But I'm definitely
not an artist.
I would like to know
well, what does that mean?
Because I look at your paintings
just off of your website,
for example, and it's
so different than what
I'm used to seeing.
Right?
Talk to me about that,
ink and paint department.
ANTONIO PELAYO: Well,
the inking and painting,
I don't exhibit that.
That's just what
I do for Disney.
MARCUS GRIMALDO: Oh, OK.
ANTONIO PELAYO: My
personal stuff is pencil.
And this piece in
particular is not pencil.
But it's from my pencil drawing.
It's a collaboration I
did with Richard Duardo.
MARCUS GRIMALDO: I saw that.
ANTONIO PELAYO: So
that's his touch there.
MARCUS GRIMALDO: Yeah,
this is your collaboration.
OK, good.
Because I saw the pencil art
that you have on your website
for this.
And then we saw this one.
And I was researching this.
It's a collaboration piece.
As an artist, is it different
being in a collaboration piece?
Because it seems when you
have your own artistry,
it's very individualistic.
It's very like, no,
this is like my story.
I'm proud of it.
It's not like you're
not segregating yourself
from somebody because
of your beliefs.
But you're just
proud of what you do.
So how was this experience being
that it was a collaboration
piece, and being an artist?
ANTONIO PELAYO: Well,
Richard saw my work.
And he said, we need
to do a collaboration.
So I told him, well, what piece?
I'll let you choose the piece.
And he chose Frida.
So I mean, I think that
collaboration was a lot of fun.
I admire Richard.
He became one of my mentors.
MARCUS GRIMALDO: That's good.
So nothing changed.
That's good.
Because, you know,
sometimes you collaborate.
And it doesn't always--
it doesn't always end
with a mentorship.
Right?
ANTONIO PELAYO: Yeah.
MARCUS GRIMALDO:
So that's awesome.
ANTONIO PELAYO: No,
Richard was awesome.
MARCUS GRIMALDO: OK.
And why did he choose
the Frida Kahlo?
ANTONIO PELAYO: Probably
because of, you know,
she's such an iconic,
just like Selena.
And she's inspired a
lot of us as artists.
She was one of my
inspirations growing up
in Mexico, her, Diego, all
the muralists from Mexico.
Yeah.
MARCUS GRIMALDO: That's awesome.
And what's the next
big thing for you?
Are you working on
anything right now
that we should be aware of?
Are you still at Disney?
Is there something new
that you're trying out?
Is there more collaborations
that we should expect?
ANTONIO PELAYO: Still at Disney.
Currently, I'm working to
expand my Familia series.
And it was a documentation of my
family's migration from Mexico.
I have a part one
and part two on that.
And I plan on expanding on that.
And also, I do some
lucha libre pieces
that I'm experimenting with.
MARCUS GRIMALDO:
That's fantastic.
So I'm going to lead us into
the theme, as I mentioned--
[SPANISH]
Right?
That's kind of where we're
at with Hispanic Heritage
Month and the theme that we want
to convey throughout Hispanic
Heritage Month.
So when you look
at your artwork,
if you had to choose
one of your paintings
or your artistic expressions--
I don't want to say
the wrong words here--
but if you had to
choose one thing that
would be representative of
that, what would it be and why?
And what does that mean to you?
ANTONIO PELAYO: For me, I
think, from Mi Familia series.
I mean, I would say all of them.
But one in particular
would probably
be a portrait of my
dad and his cousin.
And I got it from a
photo that they took.
And it was taken the day
they got deported from LA.
And it was a photo
taken in Mexico.
So I drew that.
So that, to me, you
know, meant a lot.
I can relate in some ways
because I migrated to Mexico.
And then I migrated back here.
And I wanted--
I wanted to play
with that message
and to show people
like the things
that we go through
as immigrants, things
that we feel, like feeling
lost in another country.
MARCUS GRIMALDO: Yeah,
I was going to ask you.
That must have had a profound
effect on you, being so young
and going through
that experience.
I mean, I hate
moving myself now.
I can't even imagine what
it would have been like
as a child, right?
ANTONIO PELAYO: Well, imagine
going to your hometown
and no one there likes
you because you're not
part of their religion.
And then coming back here,
I lost all the friends
that I had.
So I had no friends here.
I'm in high school.
And I hated school
for those reasons.
And when I came back
here, my English was shot.
So they put me in ESL for
about a year until I caught up.
MARCUS GRIMALDO: So imagination
was your best friend
and the pencil.
ANTONIO PELAYO:
Pretty much, yeah.
MARCUS GRIMALDO: Awesome.
Thank you for sharing.
Margaret?
[SPANISH]
MARGARET GARCIA: [SPANISH].
MARCUS GRIMALDO: What
does it mean to you?
What painting, or
expression, or artistic--
I mean, you gave
us a great intro,
a lot of strong themes here
that were very close to us, just
being [INAUDIBLE] in general.
What would be your answer
to that question, as far
as the theme that we're trying
to convey here and your art?
MARGARET GARCIA:
The public artwork
that I did for the Universal
Studios metro station.
Because it covers the
history of the Mexicano here
and in California,
and how California
became a part of
the United States,
and how it was part of Mexico.
And I worked on that
particular project--
I mean, from beginning to end,
it was a span of 10 years.
And I had a
historian, Bill Mason,
who worked for the Museum of
Natural History, who provided
me with a lot of the research in
order to get that history down.
And it covers that
period of history.
So I would have to go with that.
But other than that, I would
have to say my next painting.
MARCUS GRIMALDO: Uh
oh, I like that, next.
And how do we--
can you give us some kind of--
MARGARET GARCIA: I'm
expected to do a solo show
at the Museum of Ventura--
in the Ventura Museum of
Art in 2020, in the fall.
MARCUS GRIMALDO: OK, all right.
Well, we've got to stay
updated and stay close to that
because that's very exciting.
So congratulations on that.
And we can't wait
for that to happen.
MARGARET GARCIA: Thank you.
MARCUS GRIMALDO: Sir, your turn.
MANUEL LOPEZ: Favorite piece?
MARCUS GRIMALDO: Favorite
piece in the context
of like [SPANISH],, hear me,
what that means for you.
Again, it could be
a political sense.
It could be just
a personal stance.
It could be motivational.
I mean, I don't want to get to--
make it a contract or anything.
But I'd like to know if,
you know, given where we're
at with hear me, [SPANISH],,
and the state of where we're
at today.
You've heard the stories.
You have your narrative.
If you had to
choose one painting,
or artistic expression,
that you have,
what would that be and why?
MANUEL LOPEZ: I did what
is it, like a dictionary
back in second
grade, where we did
every letter in the alphabet.
And then we had to pick like
nine drawings for each letter.
And my mom just barely found
it a couple of months ago.
And we sat down.
And we just went through it.
And I mean, I think
that was pretty special
because you're being
introduced through a language.
Like, I feel like
my English is very--
it's not-- I mean,
I was born here.
But I grew up as
a Spanish speaker
so I still have that
very heavy accent.
And I'm just going
through the alphabet
in the English language.
And I threw in a bunch of like--
I threw in some
nopales in there.
I threw in some [SPANISH].
So just to know that you
could interplay, you know,
the cultures, and to know
that it's OK to do that.
You know, I thought that was--
I mean, just in
retrospect, you know,
seeing that a couple of months
ago, and it makes it OK.
And I just was just really happy
that my mom took care of it
after all these years.
Yeah, I think that one
definitely probably speaks--
MARCUS GRIMALDO: Wow, second
grade, I mean, that's crazy.
That's awesome.
MANUEL LOPEZ: Yeah, it was.
MARCUS GRIMALDO:
That's fantastic.
Wow, that's incredible.
Well, I think we have some time.
I want to open the floor up to
questions because, you know,
I had my own kind
of narrative here
of how I wanted to get this
and illustrate this talk.
But I know we want to hear some
from the audience, as well.
So we have time to go ahead
and do some little Q&A
A from the audience.
Right?
All right, excellent.
So anybody have any--
oh, actually, as a matter of
fact, to make it even more fun,
we have this really cool ball,
or actually cube, I should say,
I'm going to throw.
Thank you, Nilza.
So if anyone wants it ask
a question, get input,
we're here.
We're opening up the floor.
AUDIENCE: I have a question.
MARCUS GRIMALDO: Yes.
AUDIENCE: So if you
wanted to make some news,
what would that piece be about?
You want to make some news.
You're going to
break some barriers.
What would that piece be?
MARCUS GRIMALDO: You
want to make some noise.
Like, you're really going to--
AUDIENCE: Like you're going
to break some barriers.
MARCUS GRIMALDO:
Media's going to go.
Blogs are going off.
ANTONIO PELAYO: This
one's good for Margaret.
[LAUGHTER]
MARGARET GARCIA: I think that
if I wanted to make some news--
if I wanted to make
some news, then I
would want to make news because
it was worth making news about.
Right?
And right now, it just
seems that the things that
get the most news are not the
things that I particularly
care to hear about.
I'm oversaturated with
a lot of negativity
and the ill doings of people
that I don't care for.
And so if I wanted
to bring news,
I would want to bring
news to those people
in those situations,
you know, Standing Rock,
the earth, the water,
the ecology, and also
the positive things.
There are many people looking
for solutions in small villages
in Africa, in India, in Mexico.
There are people
who are invested
in STEAM, Science, Technology,
Engineering, Art, and Math.
There are people who are
trying to find solutions.
And artists are a part
of that, whether you're
talking about gentrification or
you're talking about education
or you're talking about ecology.
So for me, it's about
investing in that aspect.
What project?
I just got the East
Side Initiative.
It's called Creating
Cultural Currency.
We're interested in
creating art that
helps to teach people skills
so they can get a job,
so that they can go out
there and work using arts,
using science, to
solve those problems.
That's what I'm about.
[APPLAUSE]
MARCUS GRIMALDO: You
sound like a googler.
MARGARET GARCIA: A what?
MARCUS GRIMALDO: You
sound like a googler.
Yeah.
MARGARET GARCIA: I
am a heavy googler.
MARCUS GRIMALDO: I love it.
What about you two over here?
If you want to--
let's turn the table
upside down here.
Let's cause some disruption.
Right?
And it doesn't always have
to be in a rah-rah way.
That's kind of my take.
And my really good friend
out here in the audience
is always trying
to calm me down.
But there is ways
to do it in a more,
you know, say a
lot without saying
nothing type of way almost.
You know?
So what do you gents
think about that?
ANTONIO PELAYO: Personally,
like, my work is not loud.
So I'm not sure.
But I'm with Margaret.
I like to focus on
doing positive things.
If there was a piece
that I would create,
it would be for that,
to contribute, to help.
How to become a better
organizer-- because that's
what I do also on the side.
I organize events
that raise funds
for great organizations
like Plaza de la Raza
and how that has an
impact on the community
and the kids involved
in there, especially
because they're
involved in the arts.
MARCUS GRIMALDO: And Plaza de
la Raza, that's in Echo Park.
Right?
ANTONIO PELAYO: Lincoln Park.
MARCUS GRIMALDO:
Or Lincoln Park.
OK, sorry.
I got it.
Thank you.
ANTONIO PELAYO:
Maria's the director.
MARGARET GARCIA: Yes.
I know I talk a lot.
MARCUS GRIMALDO: No, that's OK.
Please.
MARGARET GARCIA: But I want
to say something else that I
find really, really important.
We define our community
through our culture.
And this is us.
This is how we
define who we are.
And we need to own it.
And we need to own it very
strongly because somebody
else is going to call you on
that and tell you who you are.
Instead of you
defining who you are,
you end up being in a position
where they're calling you
rapists and murderers and things
like that because they feel
they have the power to do that.
So you need to protect
that part of your culture.
And you need to define
it through the arts
by supporting the arts
within the community.
And you do that with the artist.
[APPLAUSE]
MARCUS GRIMALDO: I'm
with her, hashtag.
You don't get away so easily.
We want to hear from you.
MANUEL LOPEZ: No,
what they said.
You know, I'm kind
of quiet as well.
But right now, I'm working
with Plaza de la Raza.
And I think just
working with young kids
and showing them the
little that I know.
And also, like I think learning
from them, that interaction
going back and forth.
I also teach at
[INAUDIBLE],, which
is an indigenous-based
school in El Sereno.
And I mean, I
designed their logo.
And we carry it for
every procession we make.
I mean, the last one, the
major one, major one we had
was at City Hall to try to--
well, actually, we succeeded
in changing Columbus Day
to Indigenous Peoples Day.
And just--
[APPLAUSE]
And so, you know, it's
like Margaret said.
You know, it's about
knowing your roots.
Because we all have roots.
And you got to be--
you've got to be well
planted in order for you
to know who you
really are, you know,
and where you're
coming from, and also,
where you're going to
eventually end up at.
And even beyond that
is like the people
that you're going to
bring into this world.
You know, you just
want to have them
know who they are and, like
l said, where they came from.
So I think just
through that, you
know, little things
that we do that are
going to impact the world
hopefully for the better.
MARCUS GRIMALDO: Absolutely.
Absolutely.
Well, I think on
that note, you know,
this has been a phenomenal talk.
And again, you know,
Margaret, Antonio, and Manuel,
thank you so much
for coming and taking
the time out of your day to
share these important insights
with us.
Because again, you are right.
We are being defined--
we define our cultures by art.
And this is something
that we don't probably
pay enough attention to in life.
But we should.
And you've done a great
job at illustrating
that in our Boardwalk Cafe.
So if any of you
haven't had time
to spend time
looking at their art,
I think this is a nice
segue to not only spend
time, but understand who
the person is, the artist is
behind that artistic expression
that they have so graciously
and kindly delivered here for
us in the spirit of Hispanic
Heritage Month.
And so with that
said, I just want
to send a special thanks to
Anna Santos, Hector Carmona,
and Jeannette [INAUDIBLE]
for really helping
me facilitate this talk.
Our HOLA Global chapter, as
well as our HOLA LAX chapter,
local here, thank
you all so much
for supporting us and this.
And then last but not least,
to Nilza Serrano and the Latino
Heritage LA family because this
is a partnership that we've
come to again, a
tradition that we
want to continue with
other artists that
are doing amazing
things, like yourselves.
And so thank you
for the support here
and for helping us with this.
And then certainly again, to
you artists for coming here.
I thank you so much
for these insights.
They've been highly valuable.
And before we conclude,
you touched upon something
important.
I'm a big believer
in social media.
Again, we can't always
just have these talks.
Right?
But we do want to stay
in touch with you.
We want to know
what's happening.
We want to know what's
going on with you in 2020.
Do we have, besides a website,
do we have any Twitter,
Instagram, Facebook?
Because this is recorded
actually, live too.
So feel free to say it.
Say it slowly so
we can get it down.
But we want to know.
We want to stay in touch.
We want to follow.
MARGARET GARCIA: I
do a lot of Facebook.
I'm not too much into tweeting.
I do have an Instagram account
that I can give you the number
to for the website.
MARCUS GRIMALDO: OK.
MARGARET GARCIA: But
that's because I can't
remember all those numbers.
They've got us to the
point you can't remember
your social security number.
And they're going to
change your password.
It's really bad.
So Facebook, Margaret
Garcia artist.
MARCUS GRIMALDO: Margaret
Garcia artist, Facebook.
Señor Pelayo.
ANTONIO PELAYO: Website,
Facebook, Instagram, Antonio
Pelayo.
MARCUS GRIMALDO: All Antonio
Pelayo across the board.
All right, Antonio Pelayo.
MANUEL LOPEZ: What's my--
MARCUS GRIMALDO:
Oh, wait, email.
I think we only get an email.
No phone.
MANUEL LOPEZ: I'm
running on Instagram.
But--
MARCUS GRIMALDO: The girlfriend,
what's your social media?
No, is there a website though?
MANUEL LOPEZ: No, no website.
MARCUS GRIMALDO: No website.
Is it coming?
MANUEL LOPEZ: No, not
in the near future.
But I have the Instagram.
It's my name.
But it's all scrambled up.
Like, it's the hardest--
MARCUS GRIMALDO:
Yeah, I was looking.
Thank you.
I thought I was going crazy.
I was like, I can't
find him anywhere.
It all makes sense now.
OK.
MANUEL LOPEZ: If guys want
to follow, its meaunl_lpoez.
Damn, I got it right.
All right.
MARCUS GRIMALDO: That sounds
like one of my passwords.
I thought you didn't
have a cellphone.
MANUEL LOPEZ: No,
it's an iPod, man.
MARCUS GRIMALDO: Oh.
MANUEL LOPEZ: It only
connects when I have Wi-Fi.
MARCUS GRIMALDO:
Ladies and gentlemen,
let's give one last
round of applause.
Thank you so much.
This has been awesome.
Gracia.
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[APPLAUSE]